-Today, Senators reviewed
the FBI report
on the allegations against
Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh,
despite the fact that the FBI
didn't actually conduct
a serious investigation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
When the allegations against
Kavanaugh first surfaced,
Trump's aides
tried to restrain him.
But to literally
no one's surprise,
that facade quickly unraveled.
And in the last week or so,
he's had one outburst
after another.
-If we brought
George Washington here
and we said,
"We have George Washington,"
the Democrats
would vote against him.
I'm a very famous person,
unfortunately.
"This is so-and-so calling."
He took the call.
Why is he taking a call
from a Russian?
-I'd like to turn
to Judge Kavanaugh --
-Don't do that.
Don't do that.
Do you have --
-Mr. President --
-Excuse me.
Go ahead, please.
-Just to wrap up,
can you promise to --
-You know what?
You've really had enough.
Hey, you've had enough.
I'm not a drinker.
I can honestly say
I never had a beer in my life.
I've never had alcohol.
You know, for whatever reason.
Can you imagine if I had?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I honestly --
I honestly can't.
You already scream and yell
and slur your words
like a stumbling drunk.
Even the way you stand is
the way a drunk guy would stand
if he was trying to pretend
he wasn't drunk.
"Okay.
Just act cool."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
"Arms at your side.
Puff out your chest.
No one --
No -- No one will notice
you're swaying back and forth.
Oh.
Oh, my God, I'm gonna puke."
[ Laughter ]
The president mocked
and dismissed the allegations
against Kavanaugh,
so it's no wonder
that the FBI investigation
he requested
wasn't actually a serious
attempt to get at the truth.
Today, for example, the FBI
finally delivered its report,
and if you're wondering
how that's possible,
it's because their investigation
lasted less than a week.
They delivered the report
in under a week.
I had to do a report
on the Louisiana Purchase
in 6th grade,
and it took me a month.
[ Laughter ]
And I got a "C."
They didn't even
interview Kavanaugh
or Dr. Christine Blasey Ford.
They really went over this thing
with a no-toothed comb.
[ Laughter ]
And when they were investigating
the other allegations
against Kavanaugh,
they made it clear
they had no intention
of actually talking to people
who might have more information.
-Deborah Ramirez,
who talked to the FBI
for two hours about her
allegations of misconduct
when they were at Yale.
Ramirez's lawyer says
his client provided a list
of more than 20 witnesses
who say they could
corroborate her story.
He says the FBI has not
reached out to any of them.
-Think about that --
more than 20 people
said they might have
corroborating evidence,
and the FBI
talked to none of them.
If the FBI worked like this
on the "The X-Files,"
Mulder's landlord
could've been an alien,
and he never would've noticed.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, people who said
they could corroborate
the allegations
against Kavanaugh
actually tried
to seek out the FBI themselves,
and even then,
they were ignored.
One person
who told "The New Yorker,"
"I can corroborate
Debbie's account,"
reached out to the Bureau
last weekend
but did not hear back.
Frustrated,
he submitted his statement
through an FBI web portal.
No one should ever have to
log on to the FBI's web portal.
You shouldn't have
to contact the FBI
the same way I pay my dentist.
In fact, no one should ever
have to log on to anything
that's still called
a web portal.
"Would you like to report
a crime to the FBI?
Begin by logging on
to the information superhighway
and popping in your AOL CD-ROM."
[ Laughter ]
This investigation
was obviously a sham,
and sure enough, when the report
finally came in today,
Republican Senators
like Jeff Flake and Orrin Hatch
were quick to claim that
there was nothing new in it.
-The Senate Judiciary Committee
chairman Chuck Grassley saying,
"There's nothing
we didn't already know,"
and that there was
"no hint of misconduct."
Senator Jeff Flake
says he has seen,
"No additional
corroborating information"
against Judge Kavanaugh.
-No corroboration.
No confirmation of any
of these outrageous accusations
that have been made against him.
-We have found nothing.
Absolutely nothing
to corroborate
accusations against him.
-That's because
you didn't look for it.
You guys
are like treasure hunters
who decided to call it quits
before you flipped over the map.
[ Laughter ]
This entire process
has been a deeply revealing look
at Senate Republicans.
Trump, of course,
has always been unhinged,
but Republicans in the Senate
like to pretend
that they were all the stable,
above-it-all statesmen
who were just putting up
with his antics
to get their judges
and tax cuts.
But over the last few weeks,
many of them
have lost their minds
in Trumpian fashion.
Just take South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham.
Graham was once thought of
as a Trump critic,
but then, during the Kavanaugh
hearing, he exploded with rage.
-I cannot imagine what you and
your family have gone through.
Boy, you all want power.
God, I hope you never get it.
I hope the American people
can see through this sham.
God, I hate to say it, 'cause
these have been my friends.
But let me tell you,
when it comes to this,
you're looking
for a fair process,
you came to the wrong town
at the wrong time, my friend.
-He sounds like
an outlaw gunslinger
threatening to kill
the Lone Ranger.
But let's face it,
if it came down
to an Old West gunfight,
Graham would be the guy
hiding behind the pickle barrel
with his fingers in his ears.
[ Laughter ]
He did the same thing yesterday
when he was asked
about the President
viciously mocking Dr. Ford.
This time, Graham was in front
of an audience,
and they booed him.
-I don't like what the President
said last night.
I'm the first person to say
I want to hear from Dr. Ford.
I thought
she was handled respectfully.
I thought Kavanaugh
was treated like crap.
[ Audience booing, hissing ]
Yeah, well, boo yourself.
-Man...
[ Laughter ]
...he's just fighting
with the audience now.
He's like the least-threatening
pro wrestler ever.
"My name's Lindsey,
but you can call me
the Southern Snake,
and, brother,
I'm gonna bite your ankle."
[ Audience booing ]
"Well, boo right back at you!
You're all a bunch of meanies!"
[ Laughter ]
Graham has gone
so far off the deep end
that he even called
for one of his colleagues,
Minnesota Senator Amy Klobuchar,
to apologize to Kavanaugh.
You might remember
these exchanges
from the hearing last week
in which a furious Kavanaugh
tried to turn questions
about his hard-drinking
high school and college days
back on the Senators
asking them.
-I like beer.
I like beer.
I don't know if you --
You like beer, Senator, or not?
-Um...
-What do you like to drink?
-Next one is --
-Senator, what do you
like to drink?
-So, you're saying
there's never been a case
where you drank so much
that you didn't remember
what happened the night before
or part of what happened?
-You're asking about blackout.
I don't know. Have you?
-Could you answer the question,
Judge, and just --
So, you -- that's not happened?
Is that your answer?
-Yeah.
And I'm curious if you have.
-I have no drinking problem,
Judge.
-Yeah, nor do I.
-Ugh!
We all knew this [bleep]
in college, right?
The guy who would get pulled
over, and the cop would say,
"Do you know how fast
you were going?"
and this guy would go, "Do you
know how fast I was going?"
[ Laughter ]
And then, 20 years later, you
get a LinkedIn request from him,
and he's the CEO
of a dog-poison company.
[ Laughter ]
The only way he could've looked
crazier during that hearing
is if he was wearing one of
those beer-guzzler helmets.
[ Laughter ]
No, even Kavanaugh,
as unhinged as he was,
came back after the break
and apologized to Klobuchar,
who has written extensively
about her father's alcoholism.
Yet on Fox News this week,
Graham said
it was actually Klobuchar
who owed Kavanaugh an apology.
-Here's what I think.
Amy Klobuchar should apologize
to Judge Kavanaugh
and his family
for being part of a "schmear"
campaign I haven't seen
in over 20 years in politics.
-Excuse me. Did you say
a "schmear" campaign?
[ Laughter ]
Were you hungry
when you did that interview?
Did you just come from the deli?
"This is a schmear campaign."
[ Laughter ]
And as for Hillary,
we should lox her up."
[ Laughter ]
"I've had --"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I've had enough of her capers."
[ Laughter ]
Boooooo!
[ Audience booing ]
"Boo! You didn't like
my capers joke?!"
But that clip is such a perfect
microcosm of this entire ordeal.
Entitled, powerful men
think everyone else
owes them an apology
for having the audacity
to held them accountable
for their actions.
They think that being born
to elite status in society
means you earned that status,
and they're furious
at any attempt to take it away.
That's why Trump
keeps bringing up the fact
that Kavanaugh went to Yale,
although he doesn't always
have his facts right.
-You know, he said that really
what he was focused on
was trying to be number one
in the class at Yale.
To me, that was so believable.
I understand college very well,
and I understand
being number-one in your class,
a lot of things.
I think he was number one
in his class at Yale.
He was number one
in his law school at Yale.
He was, I believe,
number one at Yale.
Is that a correct statement?
-No, it's not.
[ Laughter ]
And I have to say,
as a favor,
you should probably
steer clear of asking,
"Is that a correct statement?"
when you're talking.
For one, we know you don't care
what the answer is.
And, also,
it would really slow down
the momentum at your rallies.
"We've accomplished more
than any administration ever.
Is that a correct statement?"
[ Laughter ]
"It's not?
What about the one before it?
Not that, either?
Have any of them been correct?
Not one?
What about when I said it's
great to be in West Virginia?
This is Mississippi?"
[ Laughter ]
-Also, can we go back
to this for a second?
-I understand college very well.
-"I understand college
very well."
Sounds like something Jack Black
would say in a movie
about a bunch of middle-aged
dudes who try to join a frat.
"I understand college,
and if we're gonna fit in,
we have go to parties and scream
at the top of our lungs..."
-I like beer.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-What we
are witnessing right now
is a cultural struggle
over how power works.
There's a set
of privileged people
who are accustomed
to being insulated
from the consequences
of their actions
and they want
to keep it that way.
That's why they set up
such a sham process.
No one who behaves
the way Kavanaugh behaved
during his testimony
should be on the Supreme Court.
And if you vote for him,
you should...
-Boo yourself.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]